now in response to that deadly attack
the city of Las Vegas increased the
number of City Marshals patrolling the
Fremont Street area there's also been an
uptick in police presence up and down
the strip Mary Jane bellies at checking
things out today
I'm here on the Las Vegas Strip near the
wind on Genting and Las Vegas Boulevard
I spoke to those visiting and working on
the strip and they tell me they feel
safe coming back to work including one
local marketing and production company
an increase in police presence seen on
The Strip today after Thursday's
stabbing which left two people dead
Rolando Espinoza is the director for
champagne Creative Group on Sunset and
Paradise the company hosts big events on
the Strip where they create cartoon
characters and contract show Girls
Espinoza says for Live Events they've
had safety protocols in place for the
last several years ensuring their
clients to speak up if they see
something suspicious we work on this
trip with with festivals and special
events all the time so you're dealing
with the public you know 15 000 people
in some cases New Year's Eve on some
cases so you get to see it all and
you're always prepared for that but Las
Vegas is very safe I think the bottom
line is it's important to say that
message is that although there's a
random attack on the Strip it has
nothing to do with a day-to-day
visitations of Las Vegas Las Vegas is
safe Javonte from Arizona is here for
his 30th birthday he says while
Thursday's incident is terrifying to
hear he's always alert when walking the
streets I'm pretty swear am I around it
so I mean I mean where am I around it so
yeah
I feel sorry for the people that got
stabbed it was super random the dude was
crazy out his mind Rowan Mustafa agrees
he arrived Thursday night from Iraq we
asked what's happening and we heard that
someone was stuck to some people and
unfortunately tour died as you said well
uh this is something weird but usually
happens uh we're okay we're safe here
but I hope this will never happen again
tonight with the pride parade downtown
and festivities all weekend expect to
see extra patrols my photographer and I
we drove up and down the strip this
morning we saw a police car every half
mile on the road reporting from the Las
Vegas Strip Mary Jane beliesza 8 News
Now